what's happening reject nation i'm greg
i'm
john we're gonna watch from the cosmic
wonder ant-man 3 plot leak
new villain and young avengers haven't
reacted to a
cosmic wonder video in a while go
through the archives of cosmic wonder
sometimes he's wrong there's actually
been a good amount of times
where he's reported on leaks that were
right now am i
lying or am i telling the truth
yes
no seriously there have been times where
he's right but sometimes
i'm lying a broken clock lies at least
five times let's just see what he has to
say okay
but he can be right a lot of the time
go follow how's it going everybody it's
warren welcome back to my channel the
cosmic
yeah whatever you [ __ ] liar i'm sorry
ant-man 3 when it's supposed to start
and when we can expect to actually see
ant-man 3
on the big screen and then of course we
have an ant-man 3
plot leak a plot leak that involves a
new hero a new villain and
whatever you have to say about predicted
for a very
long release date
for setting up the young avengers
especially with
cassie lane daughter who goes on to be
stature in the comics
so we'll talk about these new reports of
the production will we get lawrence
fishburne as goliath
the new characters and a new villain a
villain that links back to
phase two of the marvel cinematic the
best male kiss
if your new b-shirts date on everything
relating to the mcu and so you can enter
this week's giveaway for a chance to win
the dr doom funko pop
all you have to do to enter subscribe to
my channel like follows
about the video down below recently fans
were kind of confused and kind of
disappointed
because not too long ago michael douglas
in an interview was talking about
ant-man 3 and he said that we'd have
some news relatively soon
but unfortunately we really haven't
heard much in regards to ant-man 3.
i wonder why the time that we're in
right now it's rather difficult for all
of the studios because they've had to
put a lot of projects on hold but marvel
studios reshuffled their entire phase 4
lineup including some movies that aren't
part of phase 4 like captain marvel 2
but we got no word about ant-man 3. that
is
until now recently charles murphy of
murphy's multiverse.com shared a little
bit of information that he heard in
regards to ant-man 3 and its starting
production and charles murphy says
ant-man 3 has been rescheduled to begin
production in
june of 2021 and really happening
a little less than a year away from now
and as far as when to expect the actual
film
hitting theaters if everything goes back
to normal he says
ant-man 3 has not been canceled and is
absolutely still in the plans
if by some miracle everything stays on
track and long-term shutdowns are
avoided
we could see ant-man 3 in theaters late
2022 or early 2023
which is kind of great news because
obviously we have to get through
marvel's phase four before we go on to
the projects that are not a part of
facebook gotta get through it 2022
or early 2023's pretty good news for the
ant-man fans
and speaking of some good news we have a
plot leak for
ant-man 3 today now this plot leak was
discovered by screen screengeek.com and
like with all leaks
it could be true or they may not be true
so take it with a grain of salt
but as most of you know we have
discovered many true plot leaks on my
channel including some for avengers
infinity war yes it's true
it's true far from home as well
so it starts off by saying ant-man 3
will be about cassie
leaving her family to be an avenger with
scott and hope trying to stop her
now this is something that's actually
been brought up several different times
now in ant-man and the wasp we saw
a young cassie who wanted to be a
superhero she wanted to help her father
fight crime now of course obviously she
was too young at that point in time but
then
in avengers in-game we see a more grown
up
cassie lane
i don't remember this scene at all
[Laughter]
now this adds up with everything that
we've heard before about cassie lane
what we've heard in the past is that
cassie now wants to be a superhero
following in her father's footsteps but
her father
and hope do not want to let her
obviously as any good parents would not
let their children go out and take on
super villains but apparently this movie
is going to be about her
kind of running away from them going to
be an avenger and them trying to stop
her
now of course cassie is not going to
initially go on to join the normal
avengers she's going to join
the young avengers and in the comics she
plays a pretty important role on the
team of the young avengers as
stature now it sounds like we could be
getting a little bit of the story from
the comics
the comics and parents really don't want
her to have anything to do with the
avengers but cassie idolizes the heroes
especially after watching her father as
ant-man but she begins to experiment
with some pin particles that she takes
from her father
damn particle and running away to join
marvel's runaways but then she discovers
the young avengers and she would
eventually go on to join
them these guys are way cooler bigger
franchises
with cassie going on her own trying to
be a superhero then maybe by the end of
your the friends team
after all we do have a wiccan and speed
the daughter of wanda and vision coming
in the one division series we have kate
bishop coming in to take on the mantle
of hockey we have iron boy
to come in i heard him iron boy know
about his smartphone
so in ant-man 3 we're going to have
cassie lang run off and try to be a hero
on her own but of course she's going to
need help from her father scott lang aka
ant-man
and janet van dyne the wasp cassie will
most likely get in
over her head and then of course ant-man
i think you got that wrong buddy
villain in this league as well they say
that as far as the leak goes the villain
of ant-man 3
is modoc and if you're unfamiliar oh
sweet
what a man
and play the avengers game yeah i know
that's insane that's crazy
and it was used in experiments to
enhance mental power wow
very cool actually an acronym that
stands for mental organism
designed only for killing now there are
some really important things to note
here about this villain and about
aim we have had several rumors that
modoc will be entering the mcu
pretty soon and it just so happens that
the director and screenwriters for
ant-man 3
have publicly stated their interest in
having him in the film
and aim already exists in the mcu and
this is the really important part
because we have it in the past
that's why alder's killian that's why
he's saying phase two
phase four in a trailer now if you
recall back
really iron man three back in phase two
they mentioned
aim aldrich killian was actually running
that faction
and of course if you've seen the movie
you know that they've already begun to
do experiments on actual individuals
has existed in the marvel cinematic
universe for several years now and we
know that marvel
loves to tie everything back together
marvel plans ahead
years and years in advance and they
plant seeds very early on that finally
sprout
later on years later so they're
definitely going to be referencing these
events of iron man 2
plus not to mention the mandarin the
real man
are definitely going to have some call
backs to iron man 3.
and as i mentioned before we've actually
seen aim in a phase 4 project already
because we've seen
aim in one of the trailers for black
widow it's in the final trailer for
black widow right what they were calling
the final trailer at the time as we know
that there are actually two more
trailers coming relatively soon
where yelena natasha's sister in the
film is strapped down to a table
so just based off of the clip you
probably have missed it but it was
actually
charles murphy who discovered it in the
past you said
through the magic of flipping the
picture you might see the word
aim above elena's noggin this is almost
certainly
after the big final fight since she's
wearing the same outfit
and as you can see if we freeze this
picture we take a look you can't see the
words
aim right next to her
we see somebody about to give her a shot
she also has lines upon her head which
lead people to believe that maybe a face
swap is happening here but that's a
video for
the guy here
right next to her in this scene and it
looks like it's aim who's going to be
operating on her in whatever is
happening here
confirming that aim definitely still
does exist in the marvel cinematic
universe
game has existed and has been doing
experiments on people
since iron man 3 back in phase two and
now we have proof
and they're really controlling hydra oh
iii in fact in ant-man and the wasp
there was the mention of a mysterious
benefactor and we never found out who
that was that's
somebody like that just to keep him in
the dark and never explain who he was
he's definitely going to be brought into
light and most likely in ant-man 3
because they mentioned him in ant-man
and the wasp so many people right now do
believe that this mysterious benefactor
could be
modoc and this is going to be the main
that'd be gnarly
gnarly as people are calling it right
now let's face it that title just makes
sense
but this will be the villain that cassie
will initially go after herself but of
course will eventually need the help of
her father
scott lang aka ant-man and janet van
dyne
aka the wasp so if all this comes true
and all of it does seem to line up so it
looks like it probably will
we're going to get a new character in
the form of scott lang's daughter cassie
lange
taking on her superhero role of stature
played by
zazie beats the mental or
zoey for killing so let me know what do
you think about this plot league is this
something that you would like to see in
ant-man 3.
let me know what you think about it in
the comments down below and don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up to date on all things relating to the
horrible cinematic universe
for live updates y'all subscribe and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
we'll fall off thanks warren thanks
warren
woof i believe you mourin everything
that's being stated here
sounds very plausible no i don't buy it
yeah me neither these leaks man can't
trust them i believe
everything here but the fact that it
says aim in that black widow trailer
that's the only thing that has no
evidence to support
you could easily photoshop that one yeah
warren
yeah fake fake news cassie lange
becoming an important character
being like the central focus in terms of
the main characters from ant-man 3
seems like the step that this specific
franchise would go this whole franchise
has been so family based with
scott lang being the one who's kind of
outside of the family
yeah his own and the uh family
the last one you know it seemed like the
the heart and soul of it all
most of the focus was on hope janet
hank to bring it back i think full
circle for ant-man 3 and
where we left off with avengers end game
what comics fans know
of was cassie lang's future in the
marvel cinematic universe what it could
potentially be it just seems like the
right step
it seems like the perfect step i'd be
honestly very surprised
if they don't do anything with her yeah
in terms of just she's scotland's
daughter you know they have to do
something a lot more whether to bring
her to this point of stature at least
teasing it or setting up for it if not
you know being part of it they have the
five year time
jump too so she's a little bit older at
this point based off of where we left
off with her an end game well you think
that's one of the factors in deciding
that one of the many many factors is oh
yeah we could start our young avengers
even that much sooner exactly exactly
and i think with modoc being the villain
it could
probably be ant-man's biggest film
because
these films are so interesting to me
they're the like the most
underperforming ones
uh especially the way how ant-man of the
wasp was received with this box office
returns
they're hits they're still hits yeah
they're just not the
the hits mcu expects
for themselves you know isn't that a
great problem to have to be winning
so hard that a still pretty solid win is
your failure
i get the impression that even if
they're not the biggest hits that
marvel's still like
but we like it yeah that is the exact
tone i get from them and i'm actually
kind of happy that this exists because
even though ant-man is still a very
expensive you know like large-scale
movie they do appear to be on the
smaller end of that scale and i do
appreciate that somebody like marvel who
doesn't
have to invest in those things who could
go we want to invest in something that's
going to
equal mega tons more money but the fact
that they might
still you know dedicate that tlc to a
character like this is just
i think a nice thing because also i
think ant-man does occupy an interesting
corner of this world
and i think this is kind of a perfect
idea for ant-man 3 because of
what you said basically scott is often
left being on the outsider of his own
franchise
and so if you have you know even if it's
not necessarily just about her wanting
to run away but if you have some kind of
aspect where you know they're
confronting the fact that she has powers
it gives something directly for scott to
work on that's like completely tied to
him that's emotional
that could have physical stakes and now
i'm just sitting here thinking like for
every
like okay marvel franchise it's gonna be
part three where they make it like the
most important
one of this phase well it could be the
thor ragnarok of the franchise
to a certain extent yeah i hope it is i
mean you could go even trippier
you know with it totally with the uh
quantum realm and all that one thing
that bums me out in terms of hearing
about this is you know you got laurence
fishburne's character
and uh the previous one and maybe
they'll do something where louise
gets to become goliath or whatever i
don't know
i think that'd be really funny uh i
don't see it happening because i like
that luis is just
oh my gosh he's just himself you know i
mean yeah yeah
i i i can certainly see especially a la
a ragnarok
kind of tone i could definitely see luis
getting some kind of super upgrade but
at the same time part of his charm is
just that that is his specialty is his
ability to uncannily relate
scenarios back to you as hilarious
stories and
with modoc being the villain we saw the
you know the avengers trailers for the
game
that's coming out and molotov looks like
a real real formidable
foe to go up against and he's a
character who definitely fans have
wanted to
make an appearance especially
considering his relation of
uh aim with iron man 3. and i think this
would be
perfect for him to be in here not just
to
elevate the ant-man franchise think
about it in this
terms aim was introduced in iron man 3
and that was tony stark versus aldridge
killian essentially
when we all wanted the mandarin but it
was versus aldrich killian i wanted
aim at the time and then if they're
doing black widow which has a little bit
more of the world building with aim and
fuse and then modoc is a much
trippier character than
whatever aldridge killian was working on
with kilian
whatever aldrich killian was working on
with extremists bring it back to here
where you got hank pym who has always
been on the opposite side of howard
stark
you know they like they're both really
big geniuses
you know but they were rivals in a way
so if you have
this storyline where you have hank pym's
involvement here going up against aim i
just feel like there's a nice little
marriage here of stories happening where
iron man 3
tony stark going up against aim and then
here
ant-man three hank pym going up against
aim
i mean it won't be like hank fighting
personally but you know he'll be
involved in
he will be you know and it seems like it
makes sense because i mean even though
tony stark
is you know like a tech science genius
and stuff this does seem like the side
of the universe that is about scientists
you know like the whole
last movie was about them like carrying
their lab around and there's a lot of
science stuff
worked into the plot all around and and
with the way that the previous two
ant-man films have also
not quite gone for the same type of like
oh we gotta punch the big bad sort of
structure
the last couple have i like the idea
that you would have this formidable
again scientific entity with both aim
and modoc because
yeah you could do something that's just
as villainous and large scale but that
isn't the same kind of set piece that
we've seen
and that we'll you know not only call
upon the fun stuff about ant-man but
also the more science
stuff yeah that world and of those
characters it's hard not to believe this
leak there's nothing in this leak that
that seems off it seems very practical
it's like the only surprising part about
it is
having modoc in there and that's only
surprising because i wouldn't
expect the ant-man franchise to be
gifted such a
you know big such a grand villain for
the mcu just because of
usually the smaller scale
that's the surprising part about it yet
it's one of those surprises that
if it's true it makes sense it does
so that's why i would love it and i
think it's a smart business move because
if it is a success for ant-man 3 and it
is
an event bigger than the previous two it
will also inspire people to go back and
watch the previous two more
thus increasing the returns of those
films and then more people watch disney
plus
because marvel marvel marvel marvel
plans
years down the road besides the martial
marvel has it planned for when kevin
feige passes on
and then his great-grandchildren will
inherit marvel
phase eight cause that's all will be had
apparently
he's got a polygraph he's got
holographic recordings of himself
dictating
like all the hundred phases of him for
years to come
the holographic recording that tony
gives to morgan
at the end of end game is it's also
inspired by a real life
thing kevin feige has set up yeah they
cut it before it just runs the whole mcu
time by then we'll just be able to
upload his consciousness into a computer
can't
wait and he'll never die anyway guys if
this plot leak is to be true and yeah
cool she's gonna be in young adventures
big surprise
that sounds awesome all right so if this
plot link is to be true what do you
think about it
personally i think it's awesome you guys
can subscribe
to cosmic wonder subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified whenever
we got a youtube video up and last but
not least let's do up
i want to shout out cameron french today
got a special relationship
with this guy on his instagram he does
incredible
incredible list posts and uh reviews and
movies cameron's movie reviews what i
love about this individual
is every time we do a live stream he
never chimes in on the live stream
completely absent the entire time but if
we do a topic
say like sequels we want movies to he
will
message me a list of like 45 movies the
next day
he doesn't say cider topic he'll just go
like movies i want sequels to and then
just
send me an enormous list of films
doesn't comment on the live stream you
don't need a super chat or anything
you could you could say something there
if you wanted to drop a list even as
one cause he doesn't do it the reason
why he's able to send me so many
is because the man is well informed and
well knowledgeable
so trust me you will not regret
following him
on his instagram page see you guys